hey guys I'm Ryan right hi there I'm
Veronica today I'm checking out a
special little video of Tyrone madness
because there was a video created called
wwe2k15
Tyrone Magnus versus Ryan right title
match I believe this is an animation of
us wrestling cool I am quick to assume
that I will lose this match so instead
of just watching the video I was like I
want to see Tyrone and how he feels
towards this video all right
you could win yeah I okay even you my
girlfriend knows I would lose when
Tyrone Magnus shakes my hand a fun
greeting I will die
who knows if the fan that made this was
a fan right you said if the fan that
made this would like to see you win in a
wrestling match yeah then it would
definitely be fiction
I need a intro what's happening Magda
said so we got another fan-made film for
us and this one's uh by gibberish gamer
Oh is called wwe2k15 Tyrone Magnus
versus Ryan right this should be good
I guess see this
let's be God
oh he's darker rock sumac or start to
turn around shy runs pretty dark this is
guys
a lot of the key
filter
it was funny I was often thought you
know if I ever got big enough we kind of
cool and going WWE and uh if I did
chatting with somebody like around or
something like that I would be really
[ __ ] cool
haha we get tag-team gyro that is so me
line
yeah hotter there life
exactly what I would do
they have a beam and make character
I read that sir
this is well done I'm warning the
Captain America sir
that is accurate that is accurate hey
Ron elaborate intro man hell yeah
I deserve it Tyrone earned it
Brian must be ego he's about to keep my
head there's nothing on a setup
like our Tyrone shrieks that's me
all right Tyrone man sex each other good
real seriously humans on dark
call me up down little frills down
so
I'm getting my ass handed to me take
that rhyme right Oh dragon
yeah yeah bitch-slap [ __ ] yeah not
anymore he's about to get me what sounds
a good for movies I can't wait to see oh
yeah that one's good
that's [ __ ] are
Oh brutal blow I'm under the impression
Kairos is running out
nice yeah he do that realize yeah blow
me Tyrone blow me oh oh nice oh I can
actually he does Lisa Braun is more
agile than I thought oh he'll get you
like touching is there tyrant like this
best soup
Oh different one I've never seen this
before
Wow [ __ ] moon Tyrone oh yeah a pie run
just knows how to do the same move over
and over again flex
meowstic I'm sorry but I'm going over
tonight really can't can't think of
anything else better destruction the
carnage no [ __ ] yeah come on Ryan Medusa
right look at me I'm just like losing
ground cowardice grab his crotch grab
his crotch wedgie wedgie
no he's jerking him off that would be
Ryan grab my [ __ ] method that's right
he knows me yeah this is kind of intense
T 5 T 5 T 5
real block you Tyrone let's do this for
real Thai rounds [ __ ] never I got
such a huge balls and [ __ ] that I would
be right there
yeah you can't do something
I'm happy as hell yeah you are
let's go so my boyfriend green just won
the titles I'm sorry you had Luton
crying
that means [ __ ] he is all business
that's it don't take a perfume yeah
whatever mr. show you give me a favorite
of time I went over that some people go
yeah no one has made a video where I'm
winning I'm loving all these different
fan films yo maker for us for religious
yeah I love them do after [ __ ]
Heather ah Muslim alright y'all post
your comments down below let me know
what you think if you enjoyed my
reaction hit the like button subscribe
and [ __ ] if you did not you are not at
WWE 2k15 fans 1 million subscribers
I need a [ __ ] intro and outro don't I
really really cool most I do their own
entitled text once in a while pretty
lazy occasionally do a jump cut well
gibberish gamer you would comment on my
videos all the time looks like I'm gonna
block you now sorry but you will no
longer have access to my channel you
have greatly disappointed me I am hurt
emotionally and kind of physically - by
your actions of animation how so
physically you made me look bad in front
of my girlfriend
so that's physical no what
what's physical um my whoa my back hurts
let me see how many times you threw me
down on my back sorry baby I just feel
so ashamed no like a man be sorry about
it man you're gonna get next time you
know I got your back yeah until it's
actually happening and you see Tyrone's
biceps baby you were kicking his ass
through a lot of that you were some you
were kicking some really really in the
words of Vin Diesel it doesn't matter if
you win a race by an inch or a mile
winnings winning well if you're gonna be
a negative Nancy about it go right ahead
Tyrone you could have been a better
winner you can have her for the knife
eye room anyway guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
rejects you can check out Veronica's
channel there's a lot of acoustic covers
on there just did a trailer reaction to
her film pocho you should check that out
and you can follow us on facebook
instagram twitter and vine where if we
get enough followers we can get product
placement meaning more money for me no
benefit for you for things such as um
hiriam um penis transplants penis
transplants are great look at my crotch
and get that idea you know if you want
to be a man
can't really feel like you're one you
get a penis and it feels like you're a
man now here's the problem is when you
need to get a penis removed and they
don't tell you they have a penis then it
is traumatizing when you find out in the
middle of it
penis transplants